yo what up space fam goes in here from
anime uproar and i'm back to discuss
one punch man specifically garo's return
and the full extent of his current
power so make sure to stay tuned for
that if you do enjoy seeing these one
punch man videos on the channel and want
to keep them coming the best thing you
could do
is channel the caped baldy within and
serious
punch that like button until it's blue
if you haven't make this the video you
subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications or you will miss
future one punch man videos
if you have a one punch man topic you
are burning up to see
let me know what it is in the comments
below and while you wait for the next
one punch man video to drop feel free to
check out my growing one punch man
playlist that includes videos on
all s-class heroes all a-class heroes
all dragon and god level monsters
and much more link to that is in the
description
now without further ado let's jump into
it spoilers
and all so around the end of the latest
one punch man
chapter we get garrow making his epic
appearance
in a very epic looking form it's clear
that he's a whole other beast compared
to before
bang is told that his former student is
here and atomic samurai helps him out
with the villains at hand so that bang
can right his wrongs as a master by
finally putting a stop
to the human monster that is garo this
is just about as hype as it gets with
garo and his new form getting ready to
fight
bang a monster in his own right and
perhaps more
s-class heroes last time we saw garrow
he absolutely freaked out s-class hero
darkshine he made darkshine realize that
he was searching for a gratifying
victory
all the times he looked for a fight and
not a fight where the outcome was
outside of his control
darkshine's fear grew so large that garo
stopped attacking him because it almost
looked like garo was bullying the jacked
dark shine and even though garo
considers himself to be a human monster
he doesn't much like bullies
having been bullied himself as a child
as dark shine was taken away from the
wreckage
by tatsumaki's power garo was left to be
crushed by the falling boulders
darkshine currently the 11th ranked
s-class hero was psychologically broken
by garrow
he was seen after the fight sweating and
huddled in the fetal position
thinking with terror at garrow's ability
to get back up
again and again stronger and fiercer
than ever
after this scene we saw garrow still
alive and even though
he was super beat up he felt confident
that he could now
reach threat level god so what appears
to be before us
in the latest chapter of the manga
appears to be god level garo himself
and i gotta say i love garo as a villain
he says he wants to be the very
incarnation of despair
he wants everyone to cringe in fear but
the end result
is so heroic if you think about it the
reason he wants to be evil and the
monster
is so that in the face of the terror he
brings people will join hands and be
thankful for simply being able to live
injustice in those responsible for will
disappear
in a world where mere survival is a
struggle evil deeds will vanish like
bullying and discrimination and even war
rather than needing impartial justice
the world needs impartial
evil and garo will get strong enough to
give it that
or at least he thinks as much garo is
like the anti-phony hero
in reality he's a phony villain who uses
the words of evil and monsters
but is really aiming for a just society
where people don't need to worry about
discrimination bullying violence or even
war
it's a pretty warped philosophy but a
very intriguing one and hilarious one as
well and we gotta keep in mind
garo is only 18 years old so it makes
sense that he's so over the top compared
to the 25 year old saitama but back to
the question of how strong he actually
is
now well going off the manga alone we
know that he's
clearly supposed to be stronger in this
new form than he was when he broke dark
shine an s-class hero psychologically
and it's even suggested that he might be
the first
monster quote-unquote to be officially
classified as a god-level threat
of course at this point it definitely
isn't official but it's worth mentioning
because
garo was sure he can achieve god level
before we saw this new form
suggesting this is garo's god level form
now i'm going to be diving into the
webcomic from here on out which is ahead
of the manga in the story so we can
learn even more about how strong this
version of garo actually is
keep in mind the manga may change and
usually does change some things
as it moves on with the story but the
webcomic is the closest we can get to
the answer right now so if you don't
want to see any webcomic spoilers this
is about the time you want to stop the
video
for those still with me let's dive into
webcomic
garo garo does in fact go on to proclaim
that he has reached threat level god
not surprisingly all of fubuki's attacks
are useless against him
he goes on to face golden sperm an op
evolved form of black sperm who had just
made tatsumaki
the second ranked s-class hero appear
weak by comparison keep in mind black
sperm was already dragon level before
this op golden transformation
after first few punches golden says that
garo has already reached many levels
above what humans are capable of
which in theory should put him above
many more s-class heroes beyond just
darkshine
the heroes watching think to themselves
that golden is
unbeatable and yet this new garo beats
him relatively easily
at this point even if garo hasn't
officially been classified as a god
level threat he is so many levels beyond
the starting point of dragon level that
it's practically pointless to just call
him dragon level and compare him to
other dragon level monsters
garo goes on to flex on many s-class
heroes present like geno's atomic
samurai
even the second s-class hero tatsumaki
and more
stating that at his current level
tatsumaki's powers are not much better
than her sisters
which is a harsh burn to both of them
tatsumaki has all the motivation in the
world to go all
out against garo since he suggests to
her that he killed her little sister
the most important thing to her of
course we later find out that garo
doesn't really want to kill
anybody and holds back but this was the
perfect thing to say to get tatsumaki to
go all out
garo praises his own technique and says
it's reached
disaster level god so not even him but
his own technique
has reached god level and calls it
monster calamity god slayer fist
claiming it has no weak spot tatsumaki
and other s-class heroes tag-team him
but
garo is too strong and beats them all
notably tatsumaki does say
she would have done better if her brain
wasn't harmed but still
you can't take away from garrow's insane
display of easily overpowering
golden sperm and then every s-class hero
present
along with sweet mask 2. eventually
saitama and flashy flash show up before
saitama gets his turn
flashy flash with the help of other
s-class heroes again
tries to take on garo but he actually
ends up being impressed by garo
speed saying it's so fast coming from
flashy flash who's known for his speed
above all else that is
insane praise he then goes on to send
flashy flash blasting off
having beaten him in speed and
definitely in power
we are told that garu is steadily
getting stronger and no s-class hero can
eventually stand against him
it gets to the point where he's taking
care of s-class heroes with one shot
finally we get the hype battle vs
saitama and garo
of course as we can expect from this
series saitama is unfazed he takes
garo's reason for living and calls it
quran quote playing your monster game
and calls his new so-called god level
form some
cheap monster costume long story short
all of garo's blows have no real effect
on saitama and
one of saitama's punches sends garo
flying
to his credit garo does get up from this
punch and saitama slams him into the
ground
excited to see that he can keep going
after this
before the battle is over garo does
manage to dodge some punches from
saitama
and he lands countless blows on caped
baldi at one point garo despite how
strong he's gotten feels like an
insect in a cage while saitama is the
kid toying with the insect
garo undergoes quite a few forms or
costume changes as saitama calls them
where he begins to look more and more
like a monster but eventually as saitama
says
he starts getting weaker rather than
stronger even when
garo knows he's beat and the s-class
heroes are begging saitama to finish
garo off saitama refuses to because he
knows that garo
purposely held back and didn't kill the
s-class heroes he beat
he knows that garo is not as bad of a
guy as he's making himself out to be
while he was saying he wanted to be a
monster of absolute evil
what garo really wanted was to be a hero
he compromised and decided to become a
monster to bring about world peace
and according to saitama he took the
easy route thinking a monster's job was
quicker and easier than a hero's
saitama tells him that this compromised
monster hobby
could never beat saitama's serious hero
hobby
which is just hilarious i absolutely
love how he not only destroys garo
physically but philosophically too
nevertheless after a bit of friendly
thrashing from bang
saitama lets garo escape which angers
most of the s-class heroes no doubt
and that pretty much covers the scope of
this
video of course as we expected garo
couldn't beat saitama saitama used some
so-called serious moves but it was
obvious he never meant to kill garo
he was just toying with him nevertheless
that doesn't mean garo was weak in fact
garo beat multiple
s-class heroes working together and
golden sperm
and at least upper dragon level threat
that all the s-class heroes seem to fear
and he didn't have trouble with any of
this even against tatsumaki the second
best as
class hero we don't know exactly how
this will play out in the manga and how
much
will be changed or added but what i'd
love to see is
blast take on garo that would be a great
way of getting a sense of both of their
powers
especially blasts which are a pretty big
mystery at this point
in the end was this form of garo a god
level threat well it's up to
interpretation he did proclaim himself
to be a god level threat and he was
way way way above a standard dragon
level threat but he was never
officially classified as a god level
threat by others only by himself
and yes he lost against saitama but if a
god level threat needs to be able to
beat saitama then we will probably never
ever get to see an official god level
threat but that is it for this one i
hope you enjoyed it and now we have a
better sense of
what happened in the web comic and can
compare it to how the manga handles god
level garo from here on out
taking into account the similarities and
perhaps more importantly the differences
i'm very excited to see how this unfolds
and the manga tends to make very
interesting changes like using blast
more so you can bet that i'll be paying
very close attention to the
upcoming chapters if you did enjoy this
video and want to keep the one punch man
videos coming the best thing you could
do is channel the cave baldy within and
serious
punch that like button until it's blue
if you haven't make this the video you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on
all notifications or you will miss
future one punch man videos
if you have a one punch man topic you
are burning up to see
let me know in the comments below and
while you wait for the next one punch
band video to drop feel free to check
out my growing one punch man playlist
that includes videos on all s-class
heroes
all a-class heroes all dragon and god
level monsters
everything we know about blast and much
more link to that is in the description
and i especially want to thank the
patron squad over on patreon and here on
youtube who helped make videos like this
one possible
first and foremost i want to thank the
patron of legend the one acknowledged by
lord tuigo himself alpha sigma
and are the one to your patrons the ones
who stand atop all clans
ingrata pate heffa al-jatal dr cortman
the toaster chi
emperor otaku spidey life tinel tungsten
tarkis baked buddhist cody hebert
and monkey d quilly and our pro hero to
your patrons
the one and only gilgamesh the
red-haired raven angel crews
anatoly kazatsky very gucci alicia actor
bonnie parks hinokami and water joanne
garcia ted note 10 fat boy games cory
mcgowan
metal mama deadly saint and soul rise
slice and dice
thank you all so much if you do enjoy
our work you can support more of it by
going over to patreon.com
animeoutport and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these
amazing people right here and you'll
even get access to our private patron
only discord where we talk about anime
life and of course
thank memes so check out patreon.com
anime upload link in the description if
you're interested you can also join the
youtube channel by clicking that blue
join button next to the subscribe button
that you've hopefully
already destroyed so yeah you can
support more content that way if you
prefer
whichever way to support us you can get
the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you